j'ai procédé à la nomination d'un
rapporteur cela proposition de loi
visant à rendre obligatoire le
papeusement des drapeaux français
européens sur le fronton numérique le
texte sera examiné lors d'une semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale le 9 mai prochain
et j'ai reçu la courneature comme
rapporteur de Monsieur Mathieu Lefebvre
qui donc est nommé rapporteur
mes chers collègues depuis 2019 il nous
appartient alors pas mais nous
appartient d'étudier les pétitions
envoyées la Commission en application de
l'article 148 aliments et depuis 2019 la
procédure a changé je répétitions sont
désormais déposées signées en ligne
renvoyer directement à la commission
compétente en l'occurrence la nôtre pour
celle que nous allons examiner il
appartient à notre commission en
application l'article précisé soit de
décider de classer les pétitions soit de
les examiner ce qui passerait par la
désignation d'un rapporteur spécifique
pour chacune d'entre elles le bureau de
la commission des lois le 5 juillet
dernier a décidé que seuls les
pesticides ayant reçu plus de 5000
signatures dans un délai de six mois
pouvait être évoqué en commission ce
seuil est d'ailleurs plus généreux que
celui pratiqué par la majorité des
autres commissions qui les ont fixées à
10000 signatures il fait du délai de six
mois accordé aux pétition pour atteindre
ce seuil et donc logique que nous
restions deux fois par an pour les
instruire soit c'est-à-dire au début de
la session en octobre dernier ou aucune
des pétition n'avait atteint ce seuil
soit six mois plus tard si c'est donc en
mois d'avril au nous sommes ce qui tombe
donc bien puisque nous avons une pour la
première fois une pétition qui a atteint
le seuil des 100 000 signatures ce qui
permet d'avoir une grande visibilité on
applaudit pas en commission des lois on
est en ligne sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale la présidente du groupe la
France insoumise mais d'ailleurs demandé
en conférence des présidents d'inscrire
cette pétition au plus vite ce que j'ai
ce que j'ai fait puisque j'ai accédé à
sa demande je lui indiquer cependant et
c'était lors de la conférence des
présidents de mardi dernier que je
savais que nous entendions préalablement
à cet examen le ministre d'intérieur ce
que nous avons fait ce matin nous allons
donc décider des suites à donner aux
trois pétitions renvoyées à notre
commission ayant dépassé le seuil de
5000 signatures pour la clarté de nos
débats je vais donner la parole d'abord
à notre rapporteur des pétitions
Monsieur Eric pouliat qui nous donnera
d'abord son avis sur les deux pétitions
relatives à braven celle qui en demande
la dissolution et celle qui en demande
le maintien
celles et ceux qui le souhaitent pour
intervenir sur la question du classement
ou l'examen des pétitions ensuite nous
voterons cela proposition du rapporteur
monsieur rapporteur vous avez la parole
merci non c'est le rapporteur qui est la
parole de moi
merci monsieur le président
chers collègue comme les articles 147 à
151 notre règlement permettent à nos
concitoyens d'appeler l'attention du
Parlement au travers d'une pétition sur
une évolution une évolution souhaitable
du droit ou sur un sujet particulier
comme vous venez de le rappeler monsieur
le Président une nouvelle procédure
d'examen des pétitions est entrée en
vigueur le 1er septembre 2019 elle
prévoit notamment leur envoi direct des
pétitions suivant leur objet à chaque
commission compétente qui peut décider
de les classer ou de les examiner
auparavant pour mémoire la commission
des lois centralisée l'ensemble des
pétitions est décidée de les examiner de
les classer ou de les renvoyer à la
Commission
compétente je précise que le bureau de
la commission des lois a décidé le 5
juillet 2022 que notre commission se
saisirait des seules pétitions ayant
recueilli plus de 5000 signatures en
l'espace de 6 mois et que les pétitions
qui n'auraient pas atteint ce seuil dans
ce délai serait classé d'office
parmi les 366 pétitions enregistrées à
l'Assemblée depuis le début de la
législature 123 relève de notre
commission 41 d'entre elles ont été
classées d'office faute d'avoir atteint
ce seuil des 5000 signatures en 6 mois
trois pétitions en franchi ce seuil les
deux premières concernent la brave m la
troisième le référendum initiative
citoyenne en matière constitutionnelle
je présenterai donc ces trois pétitions
avant de vous faire part de mes deux
propositions de réponse mais je vais
d'abord présenter les deux pétitions
concernant la brave M
donc la pétition numéro
1319 qui date du 23 mars demande la
dissolution de la brigade de répression
de l'action violente motorisée mieux
connue sous le sigle brave M
l'auteur de la pétition estime que ces
brigades sont responsables d'exaction
violente brutale et nombreuses dans le
cadre d'un emploi disproportionné et
arbitraire de la force
il reproche à ses brigades qui seraient
le symbole de la violence policière je
cite de tendre le climat social et de
porter atteinte à la liberté de
manifester par des méthodes contraires
au schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre il compare les bravesm au
voltigeur ces unités motorisées créées
après les événements de Mai 68 puis
dissoute dissoute en 86 après la mort de
malikose en marge d'une manifestation
étudiante
il appelle à dissoudre la brave m et
conclue son texte par ces mots stoppant
le massacre
la pétition 1373 qui date du 29 mars se
présente à l'inverse comme favorable au
maintien de la brave n est-ce que les
forces de l'ordre soient soutenu face au
ordre de fou furieux qui ne jure que par
les pavés et les cocktails Molotov
c'est deux pétitions traitant du même
sujet je vous ferai part de mon analyse
conjointe
on voit bien qu'on est dans des propos
tout à fait nuancé
les brigades de répression les actions
violentes motorisées brave m ont été
créés en mars 2019 dans le contexte des
manifestations des gilets jaunes ce sont
des unités de police mobile constituées
de binômes à moto intervenant lors de
manifestations particulièrement
susceptibles de troubler leur voie
publique
opérant à Paris dans la petite couronne
elles font partie des compagnies
d'intervention de la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation de
la préfecture de police de Paris comme
la rappeler le ministre de l'Intérieur
ce matin
des unités mobiles du même type ont été
mises en place dans d'autres villes de
France sous le nom de dispositifs mixtes
de protection et d'interpellation des
NPI ainsi que dans la gendarmerie au
travers des pelons motorisés
d'interception et d'interpellation pour
les puristes les pm2i
chacune unité de bravables est composée
d'un policier motocycliste le conducteur
et d'un membre d'une compagnie
d'intervention formée au maintien de
l'ordre l'opérateur qui est mené d'une
matraque et d'un lanceur de balles de
défense appelé LBD
contrairement au peloton de voltigeur
motorisé créé en 69 auquel elles ont
elles sont parfois comparées les braves
aiment ne peuvent pas procéder à des
interpellations à des charges ou à des
tirs depuis leur véhicule depuis leur
véhicule
ce n'est que pour se déplacer le plus
vite et le plus efficacement possible
face à des attroupements très mobiles
que ces unités sont motorisées
peu présente lors des premières
manifestations intercer syndicales
contre la réforme des retraites les
braves aiment ont retrouvé un rôle
important depuis le 16 mars dernier en
raison de la multiplication à Paris des
manifestations non déclarées trop
souvent accompagnés de violences et
d'incendies
quelques chiffres pour vous décrire la
situation
lors de la seule journée du 23 mars 140
départs de feu ont eu lieu à Paris qu'il
s'agisse d'incendie de poubelle ou de
barricades avec tous les risques que
cela comporte notamment pour les
riverains
le mardi 28 mars 85 interventions de la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
ont eu lieu et un immeuble à même dû
être évacué à cause de la propagation
d'un feu de poubelle dans le troisième
arrondissement de Paris
entre le jeudi 23 et le samedi 25 425
personnes ont été arrêtées et placées en
garde à vue
42 d'entre elles ont été déférées devant
la justice
enfin selon les chiffres du ministre de
l'Intérieur
861 policiers gendarmes ont été blessés
entre le 16 et le 27 mars
ces dernières semaines des interventions
violentes de plusieurs policiers de
brave m parfois filmés et largement
diffusé dans les médias ont entraîné
l'ouverture d'enquête judiciaire et
administrative confiées à l'Inspection
générale de la police nationale appelée
igpn
dans ce contexte tendu le rôle et les
méthodes des bravesm sont aujourd'hui
débattues
l'existence même de ces brigades est
contestée par certains de nos
concitoyens comme en témoignent le
nombre de signataires de la pétition
très 119 qui s'élève à plus de 160 000
la pétition en 1373 qui a recueilli plus
de 5200 signatures est un peu plus
récente exprime toutefois le point de
vue inverse
il faut toutefois convenir que le
portrait des braves m que dresse la
pétition apparaît caricatural à
plusieurs titres
en premier lieu on ne peut pas contester
que des unités mobiles sont un
complément
utile aux traditionnel brigades de
maintien de l'ordre dans les
déplacements sont plus lents en
particulier lors de manifestations non
déclarées soudaine et par ses violences
cette justification est d'autant plus
forte dans une ville aussi dense que
Paris ou la circulation peut être
difficile
les travaux menaient sous la précédente
législature par Madame Georges Paul
Langevin et Monsieur Jérôme Lambert
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
relative à l'état des lieux la
déontologie les pratiques et les
doctrines de maintien de l'ordre
présidée par Jean-Michel Fauvergue
mettent d'ailleurs en avant le rôle
essentiel de ces unités
en second lieu il faut rappeler que les
bradennes n'ont ni pour objet ni pour
effet de restreindre la liberté de
manifestation des citoyens mais
seulement d'intervenir lorsque des
violences et des dégradations
matérielles d'une particulière gravité
se produisent en marge des
manifestations afin que les auteurs de
ces faits puissent être rapidement
interpellés et empêcher de poursuivre
leurs actions violentes
je tiens le souligner en toute
circonstances la plus grande attention
doit être apportée au respect par les
forces de l'ordre de la déontologie et
des règles de maintien de l'ordre aucun
dérapage ne doit et ne peut être accepté
et les agissements fautifs de quelques
agents appellent bien évidemment des
sanctions fermes
17 enquêtes judiciaires liées à des
manifestations ont d'ailleurs été
confiées à l'IGPN à la date du 3 avril
elle permettront d'établir les faits et
d'aboutir alors aux sanctions
nécessaires
pour autant le comportement fautif de
quelques agents qui font l'objet
d'enquête en vue de sanction ne peut pas
conduire à remettre en cause l'utilité
des bravesm dans leur ensemble lorsque
l'ordre public est gravement menacé par
des violences des dégradations et des
incendies
pour toutes ces raisons je vous propose
chers collègues de classer la pétition
en 1319 demandant la dissolution des
braves M
de son côté la pétition 1373 qui défend
le maintien de la brave m en soutien en
France de l'ordre
doit elle aussi être observée or les
pétitions en pour finalité de proposer
des réformes ou d’appeler l'attention
des parlementaires sur un problème
particulier elles n'ont pas vocation à
défendre l'état actuel du droit comme le
fait celle-ci qui appelle simplement au
maintien de la M donc pour cette raison
je vous propose également de classer
cette pétition
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur j'ai des
inscrits sur ces demandes de pétition
monsieur Gouffier valent pour le groupe
Renaissance oui monsieur
non c'est deux minutes pour tout le
monde
c'est excusez-moi monsieur le Président
parce que quand est-ce les règles qui
sont établissait deux minutes pour tout
le monde avec autant que vous voulez
donc si tout le groupe de la France
insoumise va intervenir comme il a
coutume vous pouvez le faire monsieur
Gouffier Valentin
non mais ce matin en fait monsieur vous
découvrez pas l'agenda du ministre il
était public sur le fait qu'il y avait
une audition au Sénat on a récupéré une
demi-heure supplémentaire sur l'audition
donc on peut continuer à discuter mais
en attendant on va conduire cette examen
des pétition et donc monsieur Bouffier
Valente pourra répondre oui alors si le
travail parlementaire vous convient pas
madame Martin j'en suis désolé mais
c'était une audition du ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Bouffier Valente
merci monsieur le Président et merci
monsieur le Président de rappeler
les règles de fonctionnement de nos
institutions
auxquelles bien entendu nous sommes
fidèles merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour vos propos
éclairants bien entendu nous les du côté
du groupe Renaissance nouveau tronc pour
le classement de ces deux de ces deux
pétitions la deuxième que vous avez
évoquée pour simple fait que elle ne
rentre pas dans les cadres de
recevabilité
des pétitions d'une certaine manière
elle est nulle et non avenues comme
pétition la première parce que il ne
faut pas se tromper sur son côté
caricatural makoté caracute caricatural
qui a vocation à attaquer décrédibiliser
l'ensemble de nos forces de l'ordre et
nos forces de sécurité en réalité et je
vous renvoie à l'audition que nous avons
eu ce matin du ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer Gérald Darmanin qui a
parfaitement rétabli l'effet de vérité
sur le fonctionnement de ces brigades et
de ce qu'elles apportent aujourd'hui
dans le maintien de lande et dans
l'évolution des manifestations et des
débordements et des violences que l'on
peut constater aujourd'hui et qui a on
va dire écarter bien entendu toute
les critiques que l'on peut entendre
aujourd'hui mais aussi tous les
détournements que l'on peut
observer ou entendre actuellement aussi
nous voterons pour le classement de ces
deux
pétitions et en saluant le travail que
vous avez dû accomplir en
en quelques heures pour l'étude de ces
deux pétitions je vous remercie merci
Madame Marie-France l'euro pour le
groupe rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur comme nous avons pu le voir
dernièrement des militants d'extrême
gauche viennent pour en découdre avec
les forces de l'ordre ils ont une
volonté affichée de blesser voir de tuer
des policiers et des gendarmes je tiens
tout d'abord à rappeler le soutien du
groupe rassemblement national à nos
forces de l'ordre qui sont devenues les
cibles des milices d'extrême gauche et
ne sont pas soutenus par le gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron face à cette
ultra-violence monsieur Darmanin n'est
pas à la hauteur une augmentation
importante des effectifs des forces de
l'ordre est absolument nécessaire les
forces de maintien de l'ordre présente
actuellement 25000 effectifs dont
seulement un tiers sont mobilisable du
fait du repos légal et des missions
permanentes à assurer il convient de
rappeler que sous la présidence de
Monsieur Sarkozy soutenu à l'époque par
Monsieur Darmanin deux mille effectifs
d'escadron de gendarmerie mobile ont été
supprimés dans le cadre de la loopmie
votée par le groupe RN il est prévu la
création de quatre compagnies de CRS et
de cette escadron de gendarmerie mobile
nous attendons toujours leur création
le gouvernement n'est également pas à la
hauteur sur la formation des forces de
maintien de l'ordre les moyens sont bien
trop faibles c'est pourquoi dès 2020
Marine Le Pen a proposé la création
d'une école de formation maintien de
l'ordre pour toute la police nationale
et pas seulement pour Paris comme chez
les gendarmes le vrai débat doit être
sur la formation et les moyens
nécessaires cette pétition contribue
juste à polluer le débat sur le maintien
de l'ordre en parlant de violence
policière je récuse cette expression il
faut distinguer le comportement d'un
individu et l'action globale d'une unité
comme par exemple les bravesm il faut
rappeler que les fonctionnaires de
police sont les plus contrôlés et les
plus sanctionnés en réalité l'extrême
gauche tu en a que faire de l'ordre ce
qu'elle veut c'est le chaos l'anarchie
derrière le débat sur la dissolution de
la bravème se cache en réalité le
démantèlement des bacs et le désarmement
des forces de l'ordre alors que la
nupesse nourrit par son discours les
violences qui s'accroisent dans nos rues
attisés par le mépris du peuple dont
fait preuve Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement national se positionne en
faveur de l'ordre et de la démocratie
c'est pourquoi le RN votera contre cette
position d'extrême gauche dont le texte
est particulièrement odieux et insultant
pour nos forces de l'ordre je vous
remercie pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci bon je reviendrai pas sur les
conditions d'examen de cette pétition je
me demande d'outir toutes ces
informations le rapporteur en si peu de
temps ça a été signalé d'ailleurs par
leur atteindre la majorité en quelques
heures à peine alors qu'on aurait pu
convenir quelques auditions pour au
moins examiner ces pétitions parce que
le règlement notre règlement le
règlement de l'Assemblée ne dit rien en
la matière mais absolument rien ni qu'on
peut faire des auditions ni qu'on peut
ne pas en faire donc on aura pu en faire
4 5 j'aurais pu auditionner le chef de
la bravème vous aurez plus le préfet le
préfet de police Gérald Darmanin bon ça
c'était fait ce matin mais ça
ressemblait pas tellement une audition
mais voilà jusqu'à 5 en deux semaines
c'est possible et en vérité pour vous
l'opportunité était trop belle trop
bonne de classer cette pétition parce
qu'il faut dire les choses votre
objectif et qu'elle soit placée pour
qu'il n'y ait pas 500 000 pétitionnaires
pour que vous ne vous retrouviez pas à
devoir répondre de l'organisation d'un
débat ou non dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale dans des
conditions qui soient un peu plus
loyales que celle de la Commission de ce
matin voilà les éléments centraux
là-dessus quant à l'examen en tant de
cette pétition monsieur le rapporteur on
nous demande pas de valider
le fond de la pétition c'est pas ça le
sujet c'est ce qu'on l'examine est-ce
que c'est un sujet intéressant à
examiner ça ne dit pas si on est
favorable défavorable et quand vous avez
260 000 citoyens qui signent par France
Connect en plus déjà ça c'est une autre
histoire enfin je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'il vous faut de plus 270
000 300 dites votre chiffre on va
l'atteindre il y a pas de problème
laissez-nous un peu de temps on va
l'atteindre mais ne balayez pas comme ça
par un 49 3 de la commission une une
pétition qui a sa légitimité dans le
pays regardez le sondage du point
commandé par le point la France
insoumise qui a commandé le sondage sur
qui à la responsabilité des violences
dans ce pays quelle est la vie des
Françaises et des Français en numéro 1
38% responsabilité le gouvernement
ça devrait vous interroger ça vous
intéresse la vie des Français mais non
visiblement non puisque vous classez
sans suite une pétition signée par
260000 personnes
je pensais que vous aviez reçu mon
courrier mais manifestement ou de l'avez
ni reçu nilue puisqu'il vous rappelle
que les auditions ne sont pas organisées
préalablement à l'examen des pétitions
mais seulement si la pétition est votée
et renvoyée au fond non c'est pas moi
qui le dis c'est le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur
bernalicis d'ailleurs vous l'auriez su
si vous aviez lu le courrier que je vous
adressé le courrier que j'ai pris la
soin de vous adressez en particulier et
non de publier sur les réseaux sociaux
comme vous l'avez fait je rappelle
simplement que cette audition en tout
cas cet examen des pétition a lieu à la
demande de votre président de groupe
n'a-t-il panneau formulé le 28 mars à
laquelle j'ai immédiatement accédé et
donc que ces cas particulièrement
spéciale de votre part de demander le
report de quelque chose que vous avez
vous-même réclamé voilà donc vous pouvez
organiser le tumulte autour de cela vous
pouvez organiser le tumulte autour de ça
et par ailleurs je rappelle pour une
dernière chose sur la question mais moi
je fais pas de coup politique monsieur
bernadisse moi je fais du droit
contrairement à vous je vous ai déjà
expliqué pourquoi vous ne respectez pas
le droit et pourquoi vous aviez pris
quelques légèreté avec le règlement
dernier élément pour l'examen en séance
de l'appétition si jamais à l'Athénée
500 000 signatures il y a préalablement
un vote en commission et c'est la
commission devant laquelle nous sommes
Monsieur Xavier Breton pour le groupe
les républicains oui merci monsieur le
Président oui on a effectivement examiné
le rapport de notre collègueulasse sur
deux pétitions qui traitent des brigades
de répression de l'action et l'autre
motorisée je crois qu'il y a
effectivement un droit à la pétition
mais ensuite ça donne pas
obligatoirement un examen automatique
systématique et c'est effectivement le
filtre que nous sommes amené à faire moi
je voudrais saluer le le rapport de du
collègue qui montre effectivement que on
a des une présentation dans les
pétitions qui est partial qui est même
caricatural par certains points et
qu'effectivement
ben je crois qu'on est là aussi pour
faire preuve d'un peu d'exigence
dans la présentation des choses et de ne
pas rentrer dans une partialité
militante qui discréditerait notre notre
travail donc je crois qu'il y a
effectivement des mécanismes internes
qui permettent que les enquêtes soient
réalisées et
encore une fois ça permet effectivement
que dans le cas de nos fonctionnements
de nos institutions ces questions soient
traitées mais effectivement je crois
qu'on n'a pas
à rentrer dans des logiques de combat
idéologiques et médiatique qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre et c'est pour ça
que nous soutiendrons le classement de
ces pétitions telles que nous propose
leur apporter
monsieur Roger Vico pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le Président
considéré qu'une pétition est non
recevable ou à classer selon
l'expression consacrée ça n'efface pas
le sujet 260
000 signataires et même un peu plus
c'est quand même le révélateur d'un
malaise réel c'est le révélateur aussi
d'interrogations qui sont tout à fait
légitimes et je crois qu'aucune pétition
depuis la création de la plateforme
avait passé la barre des cent mille
signatures
moi je ne voudrais pas que
on met la tête dans le sable et que on
considère comme la considérer ce matin
le ministre d'intérieur que la violence
traite par la violence et circuler il y
a il y a rien à voir
l'échelle de perroquet c'est
aller inéluctablement vers une issue
tragique que j'imagine personne ne
souhaite ici si elle devait être le cas
malheureusement demain je pense que vous
seriez tenu de regarder tout à fait
différemment ce type de pétition et ce
type de requête cette procédure de la
pétition et nous le regrettons ne
devrait pas offrir comme celui-ci un oui
ou un nom en réalité c'est le cas
pourquoi parce qu'une fin de recevoir
c'est toujours brutal et que dans le
contexte de tension sociale inédite que
nous connaissons
il serait bienvenue que l'on puisse
avoir un débat pour
réinterroger parce que nous avons le
faire régulièrement la doctrine
française en matière de maintien de
l'ordre et notamment son évolution
récente qui est contestée à la fois par
des citoyens français mais aussi par des
observateurs internationaux je veux
juste rappeler ici que l'autorité ça ne
peut pas être l'entêtement et que nous
ne pourront pas ce classement en tout
cas s'agissant de la pétition qui a reçu
le plus grand nombre de signatures parce
que l'autre nous intéresse peu pour ne
pas dire pas du tout et je terminerai
simplement en disant que interroger les
conditions du maintien de l'ordre ça
n'est pas remettre en cause le travail
des forces de l'ordre c'est se placer du
côté des valeurs de la République quand
certaines pratiques semblent s'en
éloigner merci Monsieur Philippe Pradal
pour le groupe horizon
sur le président monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues plusieurs centaines de
policiers gendarmes ont été blessés lors
de récentes manifestations c'est
inacceptable le groupe Horizon est
apparenté salut l'engagement de ces
femmes et hommes qui consacrent leur vie
professionnelle et trop souvent une
partie de leur vie personnelle à
l'intérêt général à la protection de
leur concitoyens et à celle de nos
institutions il est important de
distinguer les manifestations organisées
et sécurisées en grande responsabilité
par les organisations syndicales d'un
côté et l'émergence de groupes de
casseurs d'extrémistes et autres Black
Blocs de l'autre venus parfois de
l'étranger pour générer de la violence
contre nos institutions et leurs
représentants dans ce contexte de
violence et de conflictualisation de
notre société la question de la
politique de maintien de l'ordre et
central et la pétition visant à
dissoudre la brade n nous interroge à
deux titres d'une part parce que nous
estimons qu'il revient au ministre de
l'Intérieur compte tenu des informations
et des moyens dont ils disposent
notamment de renseignements de décider
dans le cadre du schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre validé par le
Conseil d'État de prendre les décisions
qui s'imposent en matière d'organisation
du maintien de l'ordre
ne signifie pas que ce dernier est
exonéré de contrôle parlementaire je
rappelle que nous avons auditionné ce
matin monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur d'autre part dans le
contexte de manifestation interdite
menée par des extraits et des casseurs
dans le tracé n'est pas connu le groupe
Horizon est convaincu de la nécessité
pour l'état de se doter de force mobile
pouvant réagir vite et se déplacer
rapidement d'un pantalon si certains
policiers au gendarmes ont pu adopter
des comportements non conformes à la
déontologie ils seront sanctionnés et
c'est pour cela qu'il est inadmissible
et inacceptable de chercher à jeter
l'eau propre sur ces femmes et hommes
qui défendent l'ordre républicain le
groupe horizon y apparenté souhaite donc
que cette pétition soit classée il en
est de même pour celles qui demandent le
maintien de la bravène qui n'apporte
aucune solution nouvelle et relève à
notre sens du pouvoir d'organisation du
ministre de l'Intérieur
merci même sans Argol pour le groupe
écologiste merci monsieur le président
de leur impact de vérifier ce qui se
passe et de mettre à la transparence sur
leur action et leur modalités des
laboration nous sommes le pas
complètement folle c'est aussi le sens
de cette pétition le problème c'est
qu'entre temps les violences qu'on
commis certains des agents parmi la
centaine qui exercent à l'intérieur de
ce brave on choquait beaucoup de monde à
commencer par les agents de police qui
voient leur travail et leur activité
encore une fois abîmées par quelques
personnes qui ne respectent pas les
choses je rappelle quand même que rouler
sur le corps dans manifestum ça fait pas
partie de ce qui constitue le cadre
légal de leur action insulter les gens
et le proposer de je cite les ça
ne fait non pas non plus partie du
travail de ce qui peut revaloriser la
police je pense que nous serons toutes
et tous d'accord là-dessus
mais ça aussi provoquer des images à
l'international terrible sur comment la
France ne gère pas
la sécurité pourquoi parce que dans les
autres pays il y a des manifestants
violents aussi on va prendre dans les
hooligans les néo-nazis peu importe mais
il y a pas en revanche des images comme
ça parce que l'organisation n'est pas la
même
la question que je me pose c'est je vous
ai entendu je sais que les propos
utilisés dans cette pétition ne
conviennent pas pourtant elle a eu
beaucoup de signatures c'est pas rien
c'est un signal ça veut dire qu'il y a
une demande de transparence ça veut dire
qu'il y a une demande de mesure d'impact
de travail démocratique dessus et je
comprends que les mots qui sont utilisés
les arguments qui sont utilisés puis
sortaient une partie d'entre vous nous
n'avons pas la même culture nous n'avons
pas le même prisme politique en revanche
vous ne pouvez pas taire la demande qui
vient de la population et qui demande
qu'il y ait un travail dessus c'est
pourquoi je vous demande de prendre en
compte la demande qui vient de la
population vous avez pas du tout c'était
élu par les citoyens de respecter ça
pour qu'on puisse avoir un discours
dessus un travail parlementaire dessus
le président
je comprends qu'on puisse avoir un débat
en interne avec certains responsables
politiques de l'extrême gauche de
l'hémicycle la réalité c'est que depuis
le départ vous tapez sur la police et
vous dites que la Bravet me responsable
de beaucoup d'exactions par rapport aux
vidéos qu'on a pu voir peut-être il y a
des enquêtes en cours laissons les faire
mais à aucun moment à aucun moment vous
avez appelé à l'apaisement à aucun
moment vous avez dénoncé les violences
aussi de certains manifestants à aucun
moment vous n'avez demandé vous avez
contesté le fait que certains de vos
collaborateurs eux-mêmes à la aller
volontairement non c'est la vérité c'est
pas un problème c'est en ligne pas de
problème vous pouvez le faire ici j'ai
rien à me reprocher vu que c'est en
ligne et que c'est la collaboratrice
qu'il a fait elle-même et que le député
lui-même a reconnu la légitimité des
violences à partir de là il faut en
assumer aussi les conséquences la
question qui se pose c'est que d'une
part même si la pétition pouvait être
vue de notre côté ce n'est pas une
réponse législative parce que c'est du
réglementaire l'organisation du
ministère de l'Intérieur et si demain on
a une pétition qui fait 400 000
signataires qui demandent le
démantèlement de la France insoumise
allez-vous la soutenir
madame Marie-France l'euro c'est votre
tour
c'est votre tour vous aviez demandé la
parole
non alors Monsieur Antoine
écoutez on s'amuse beaucoup de votre
ridicule pour
contester la légitimité d'une pétition
qui recueille 260 000 signatures vous
voilà en train d'étudier une pétition
pour le maintien de la braven qui en
compte 5000 et cela vous oblige aussi à
parler du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne constitutionnel on se marre
trop parce que ça part d'une pétition
sur la brabais mais à la fin vous allez
parler carrément de la Constitution et
du droit des citoyens à réformer leur
constitution faites attention parce que
la pétition pour demander la destitution
d'Emmanuel Macron est à 4818 signatures
et donc peut-être que bientôt nous
discuterons ici de la destitution du
président lui-même plus largement vous
êtes désormais dans un une forme
d'autoritarisme qui est absolument
incroyable vous venez de décider en
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale de punir
les députés insoumis parce qu'ils ont
chanté la Marseillaise l'hymne national
et vous n'avez pas honte de faire cela
vous êtes minable dans vos méthodes et
je crois que le ridicule le ridicule de
l'autoritarisme macroniste est en train
de se faire voir sur tous les tableaux
alors chers collègues puisque vous
n'aimez pas Robespierre je vais vous le
citer le droit de pétition est un droit
imprescriptible de tout homme en société
les Français en jouissent avant que en
jouissait avant que vous puissiez
assembler les despote les plus absolus
n'ont jamais contesté formellement ce
droit à ceux qu'ils appelaient leur
sujet plus un homme est faible et
malheureux plus il a le droit de
pétition c'est le droit imprescriptible
de tout être intelligent sensible
Maximilien de Robespierre discours du 11
mai 1791 voilà Robespierre vous donne
une leçon et vous qui aimez à le citer
en parlant de la terreur vous êtes avec
cette politique de violence policière en
train d'appliquer vous une politique de
la terreur contre les manifestants donc
vous êtes absolument ridicule dans votre
manière d'essayer d'enterrer cette
pétition et il y aura ce soir à 19h
beaucoup de gens à l'hôtel de ville pour
vous signaler le ridicule de ce que vous
faites Monsieur Thomas porte
merci
effectivement je il y a quand même une
forme de ridicule pour reprendre les
propos de mon collègue Antoine vous êtes
en train de trembler devant une pétition
voilà aujourd'hui vous en êtes tellement
vous êtes enfermé dans un 49-3 à
l'Assemblée aujourd'hui vous voulez
enterrer une pétition qui pose un sujet
majeur parce que là vous évoquez d'air
moi je m'interroge on n'avait pas
désigné ce rapporteur là pour la
pétition de la du soutien à la brave
personne n'avait décidé ça donc ça a été
pris dans quel sens non non
en faisant du droit
j'étais là à 8h30 ce matin mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous nous
vous nous parlez de partialité on a eu
un exemple ce matin avec un ministre qui
a fait preuve de partialité qui nous a
présenté un PowerPoint avec des éléments
à charge mais qui a été totalement
ridicule simplement aujourd'hui vous
pouvez pas évacuer sur le tapis qui est
260 000 citoyens qui est signé cette
pétition et oui c'est une pétition
engagée mais toutes les pétitions ont un
objectif engagé elles ouvrent un débat
elle pose une question sur le maintien
de l'ordre et la braven et la pointe
avancée de votre politique de répression
de gens qui oui roulent sur des
manifestants mettent des coups de
matraque tiennent des propos racistes le
soir est-ce qu'on peut accepter d'avoir
des policiers qui se comportent de cette
manière qui aujourd'hui disent à des
gens mais tu es venu en France parce que
tu as traversé la mer où tu t'es
accroché à une aile d'avion voilà
aujourd'hui ce qu'est la braven et nous
allons continuer à porter la
mobilisation pour exiger la dissolution
la dissolution de cette unité là qui est
une unité violente et je remarque que ce
matin
Gérald Darmanin a dit mais on peut pas
les dissoudre parce que c'est pas une
unité vous avez vous-même rappelé que
c'était une unité donc je sais pas où
est la vérité je sais juste que Gérald
Darmanin est expert en mensonge qui
continue à les proférer cette brigade là
n'a rien à faire dans le maintien de
l'ordre c'est un danger elle menace les
gens elle s'aime la terreur le soir dans
les rues de Paris et après il faudra
assumer si un drame qui se produit dans
les prochains jours parce que ces gens
sont dangereux aujourd'hui
mais la mélise à Martin
merci moi je veux juste
insister sur sur l'aspect suivant ça
n'est pas au député de la France
insoumise
à qui vous donner une fin de
non-recevoir c'est au 260 000 personnes
qui ont pris la peine de signer voilà et
qui de surcroît on suivit une procédure
qui ne relève pas du fait de se mettre à
la sortie de je sais trop quel endroit
et de relever de cette façon là
peut-être même à la va-vite un certain
nombre de signatures ils ont suivi une
procédure au sein de laquelle ils se
sont déclarés au sein de laquelle ils
peuvent être
identifiés donc ça n'est pas une
démarche
marginale ou qui n'aurait pas de sens
donc encore une fois cette fin de
non-recevoir ça n'est pas à nous qu'elle
s'adresse c'est bien à ceux qui
effectivement ont pris la peine de lire
et de signer cette pétition pourquoi
est-ce qu'il s'est passé ça en si peu de
temps quand même reconnaissez avec nous
que il s'est passé quelque chose autour
de cette pétition sinon elle n'aurait
pas recueilli 260 000 signatures en un
temps quasiment record qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ça signifie que cette police là
les effets et on comprend que ça puisse
les effrayer parce que malgré la
conférence de presse du ministre de
l'intérieur de ce matin il y a un
certain nombre de faits et l'effet vous
le savez sont têtus qui peuvent tout à
fait justifier cette effroi et là où ça
devient terrible y compris pour les
policiers que vous prétendez défendre
sans cesse et sans cesse c'est que
l'organisation en mode là brave m
devient le modèle devient le symbole de
la police or la police en France c'est
quand même pas ça mais la manière dont
vous insistez y compris pour
disqualifier ces 260 000 personnes qui
ont signé vous ne faites que renforcer
police population et c'est votre choix
[Musique]
on peut se poser la question
effectivement de la légitimité sur le
fond ou sur la forme mais ici il faut
quand même reconnaître qu'on a une
démarche démocratique qui est assez
inédite très rare moi je la connaissais
pas vous voyez avant que quand on la
propose nos citoyens et que elle soit
déclenchée donc on a une rareté de cette
procédure pétitionnaire auprès de
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que tout
le monde conviendra que nous ne la
connaissions pas auparavant ce qui est
étonnant c'est que les attendus du
rapporteur ici se substitut
autoritairement à la requête des
citoyens c'est à dire que finalement on
fait une position pour les consulter et
vous vous faites le consultant alors pas
ma Kinsey bien sûr sur ce coup là mais
le consultant d'autorité qui décide
finalement de l'issue de la légitimité
et de du résultat de de cette démarche
démocratique
l'expression de la volonté populaire
doit s'exprimer avec un avis une opinion
et ici les avis des orateurs se
prévalent du vote des pétitionnaires
alors pour moi c'est un déni de
démocratie absolue mais enfin on
commence à avoir beaucoup l'habitude
elle a des la dictature c'est ferme ta
gueule la démocratie c'est cause
toujours
ce classement est de nature a dissuader
les citoyens et les électeurs de
recourir à ce droit pétitionnaire si
vous ne l'acceptez pas pour ce cas-là
alors pourquoi vous allez l'accepter si
c'est pour choisir la couleur des fleurs
que vous allez donc vous allez pas
boiser l'Assemblée nationale ça présente
pas un intérêt démocratique très évident
et vous craignez quoi les conclusions
d'un examen parlementaire il aurait pu
être de nature à légitimer l'usage de la
brave non mais vous vous refusez de
prendre le risque que cet examen pointe
au contraire la légitimité de la
dissolution de cette brave m donc vous
voyez vous avez même pas le courage de
laisser le dispositif se dérouler
jusqu'à son terme et qu'il aboutissent à
un examen parlementaire vous avez
décidément un vrai problème avec le peu
d'expression démocratique que nos
institutions ont abandonné au peuple
français et vous continuerez à peindre
la déploration de la désaffection des
urnes par les Français continuer madame
Daniel Bono
oui alors notre collègue Mendès à
l'instant nous a interpellé en affirmant
que nous n'appelions pas l'apaisement je
pense que il se trompe parce que
précisément appelé à participer à ce
processus qui a pas été mis en place par
la France insoumise qui a été mis en
place comme une manière d'ouvrir aux
citoyens donner un peu de levier de
pouvoir d'interpellation d'intervenir
dans le débat parlementaire c'est une
forme d'apaisement c'est une forme de
manière de dire dans quel cadre et dans
les cadres institutionnels dans les
cadres institutionnels on peut
s'exprimer on peut faire entendre des
points de vue différents y compris parce
que ce débat s'il avait eu lieu s'il
pouvait avoir lieu il ferait entendre ce
qu'on entend ici de la part des
collègues qui interviennent au fond et
pas sur la forme il me semblait que
c'était pas vraiment le but de la séance
en commission mais il faudrait entendre
tous ces points de vue et je crois que
ça appartient participerait à
l'apaisement en fait le fait que ça
puisse exprimer que les points de vie
soit entendus y compris même sans vote
mais il nous semble en tout cas c'est
nous notre conception des institutions
c'est que ça doit être des canaux voilà
ou y compris des expressions de colère
puisse trouver une forme de sublimation
par l'expression parlementaire les
positionnements etc et je crois que vous
faites une erreur non seulement comme
l'a dit la collègue Martin parce que
c'est une fin de nos recevoir pas tant
au député de la France insoumise nous on
en a l'habitude mais aux citoyens qui ne
sont pas des
ultra gauchistes ou je ne sais quoi
enfin ils peuvent être d'extrême gauche
il n'y a aucune honte d'extrême gauche
dans ce pays il y en a et c'est tout à
fait légitime ce n'est pas encore
interdit en tout cas
pas encore mais mais mais mais des gens
qui ont été interpellés et qui auraient
aimé avoir entendre ce débat et je crois
que c'est vous discréditer vous-même en
fait les institutions et les procédures
paléatives que vous avez mis en place et
Madame Nathalie vous en paierez les
conséquences
Nathalie
monsieur vous avez la parole
pour vous
Madame
s'il vous plaît
si vous prenez pas la parole j'ai
distribue à quelqu'un d'autre merci
monsieur le président
bon je viens ici donc il vous aura pas
échappé que je ne suis pas membre de la
commission des lois mais pour autant il
me semble que ce qui est proposé ici par
mon groupe la France insoumise à savoir
une pétition permettant de rendre
transparente les méthodes
données les directives données aux
unités de la bravème
ceci est une bonne chose
on repart au début il s'agit tout cela
s'encre dans le la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites à 64 ans qui
est massivement rejetée par les gens qui
n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
que le gouvernement a fait adopter de
manière verticale par le 49-3 dès lors
une contestation s'est mise en place par
les manières traditionnelles par les
voies traditionnelles 10 11 12 journées
de mobilisation à l'appel d'une inter
syndicale unie toujours uni aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs lorsqu'elle a été reçue par
Elisabeth borne et qui demande toujours
le retrait de ce projet de loi 93% des
actifs et des actifs ne veulent pas de
cette Ret à 64 ans dès lors le
gouvernement choisi de mettre en place
des moyens de répression violent
arbitraire qui s'éloigne du cadre
démocratique et du cadre républicain et
suite à cela un autre moyen de
contestation démocratique et proposée
celui de cette pétition et voilà que
vous voulez classer cette pétition vous
voulez faire taire l'opposition qui est
constitutif pourtant d'une démocratie
saine vous voulez perdre disparaître
toute proposition apaisée pacifique de
sortie de crise alors qu'il est urgent
de trouver le chemin de la désescalade
dans ce pays parce que nous sommes dans
une impasse nous sommes dans une impasse
mais désormais c'est le gouvernement qui
est à la vue de tous minoritaires voire
même un seul homme qui décide depuis son
palais et qui refuse de céder à ce que
demande la majorité des gens donc en
plus d'être autoritaire toutes ces
méthodes sont vaines elles sont veines
l'opposition des Françaises et des
Français à votre politique et bien là
dont vous pouvez classer toutes les
pétitions que vous voulez ça ne changera
pas une ambiance de ce pays donc il faut
trouver la solution
merci monsieur le Président on entend
beaucoup parler les élus d'extrême
gauche de violences policières de
massacres et on y est habitué c'est leur
fonds de commerce mais surtout l'extrême
gauche et on en a eu la preuve la
semaine dernière il légitime les
violences et les tentatives de meurtre
de leurs amis des Black Blocs et autres
milices d'extrême gauche qui utilisent
des cocktails Molotov qui sont des armes
de guerre et on a tendance aucun membre
des forces de l'ordre à utiliser une
arme létale pour répondre à ces à ces
attaques on voit des hommes et des
femmes qui se transforment en torche
humaine en torche humaine et vous
légitimez c'est violence
vous légitimez ces violences donc nous
notre position elle est claire en fait
les 260000
pétitionnaires sont quasiment
exclusivement je pense des militants
d'extrême gauche qui se retrouvent
certainement avec vous sur les manifs
sur les manifs interdites comme vous
comme vous y êtes rendu dernièrement et
de toute façon avec vous on est on n'est
jamais surpris on a toujours pour pour
le bon compte
et
vous et vous je suis certain que de
toute façon après les braves m il y aura
également d'autres services de police
que vous attract vous attaquerez comme
vous l'aviez déjà fait avec les bacs
donc de notre côté on s'opposera à cette
à cette pétition que vous avez lancé
avec tous vos amis des milices d'extrême
gauche monsieur le rapporteur pour votre
vos réponses oui merci monsieur le
Président je vais faire dans l'ordre
pour que ce soit plus simple
le silence si possible alors notre
collègue bordel ici bon comme d'habitude
chers collègues je vous laisse à vos
propos comme toujours accus à toi et
avec une indignation non feinte et
je voulais juste vous dire que je me fie
moi mon à notre règlement notre
règlement qui est bien le nôtre et qui
et non notre Règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale de l'Assemblée nationale que
je pense le Président vous a rappelé et
donc nous avons effectivement à partir
de 100 000 une publication et jusqu'à
500 000 un examen non obligatoire avec
un rapport donc que ce soit 200300 400
850 000 c'est pas une question en deux
jours c'est on suit le règlement voilà
le respect de nos institutions et de du
règlement et ma boussole et je vais ça
le restera je pense contrairement à vous
le sens madame rigole vous avez parlé du
sens de la pétition qui serait la
transparence non c'est pas c'est pas ce
qui a écrit enfin on n'a pas lu la même
chose alors parce que c'est
effectivement pas du tout ce qui a écrit
ce qui est demandé c'est une des
solutions en comparant donc la bravème
au voltigeur en citant malikine et en
parlant de massacre de massacre le mot
massacre a un sens voilà donc moi je
l'ai dit dans le je l'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire je ça ne l'utilisation
de la bravène me paraît nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour répondre à une violence
qui s'est fortement accrue dans son
intensité notamment mais ça ne cautionne
en aucun cas tout usage de la force qui
sort du cadre légal et donc encore une
fois je le dis il faut laisser Ali GPN
le temps de faire la transparence sur
tous les faits que vous avez cité ici et
si c'est fait existe ils sont alimentés
de la façon juste l'IGPN prendra les
sanctions et je serai à vos côtés pour
me féliciter que
de la force non
légitime soit condamné
les images qu'on a vu ce matin vous avez
dans votre propos indiqué que quelque
part ignorer qu'en France je crois que
les images qu'on a vu ce matin avec la
mise à l'intérieur de la police
allemande ou autre montre montre que il
n'y a pas qu'en France qu'en US de la
force voilà mais il n'y a pas qu'en
France qu'on utilise la force et c'est
comme ça parce que malheureusement aussi
les activistes les activistes les
activistes qui sont violents ne sont pas
violents qu'en France ils sont aussi
violents ailleurs et toutes les polices
du monde aujourd'hui on va faire à eux
monsieur
oui
c'est faux c'est faux ça existe dans
d'autres pays je peux vous assurer
regarde d'ailleurs en Allemagne regardez
dans les sommets internationaux etc ça
existe dans plein d'endroit alors
Monsieur léoman alors je suis toujours
admiratif que vous étiez Robespierre je
rappelle corbeille pierre a été
raccourci par les révolutionnaires
eux-mêmes parce que étant à considéré
comme un sanguinaire perd de la terreur
donc si vous voulez pour me donner le
centre démocratie pour me donner des
leçons de démocratie c'est rater
c'est c'est quand même celui c'est quand
même c'est quand même celui c'est quand
même celui qui a c'est celui quand même
qui a condamné à mort Danton il a
condamné à mort dans ton quand même qui
je pense était aussi la révolutionnaire
allez allez
c'est pas un cours d'histoire révolution
je remarque que c'était Robespierre pour
parler démocratie ça reste quand même un
paradoxe assez alors ensuite je crois
que c'est monsieur porte qui a parlé de
politique de répression de semer la
terreur donc on voit bien effectivement
qu'on retrouve exactement le même
registre que celui de la pétition
et je le répète encore une fois si il y
a eu des si
s'il y a des actions un petit qui
sortent du cadre légal elles doivent
être elles doivent être réprimées et
sanctionnées et il y a je crois qu'on
est tous d'accord pour dire ça ici
je suis le règlement encore une fois sur
le traitement de cette pétition pour
rejoindre ce qui a été dit aussi par
d'autres collègues ce que cette police
effraie
moi je suis je pense qu'elle est fraîche
surtout ceux qui essayent de commettre
des violences puisque on voit que son
usage aujourd'hui
fonctionne accessible je crois que et je
crois très très sincèrement que
aujourd'hui elle gêne elle gêne des
actions violentes elles viennent des
actions violentes et elles gêne aussi
ceux qui souhaitent mettre le désordre
et troubler l'ordre républicain donc je
suis tout à fait content qu'elle puisse
gêner le ceux qui veulent troubler
l'ordre public et à partir de là
elles n'ont pas effrayé le citoyen
encore une fois je dirais un peu dans
mon propos elles ne sont pas là pour
cela donc quand enfin aux propos qui ont
été tenus sur la dimension un peu
impérative de la pétition sous le
principe que parce qu'il y aura une
pétition on devrait l'examiner on serait
sous finalement l'ordre sous les ordres
du citoyen encore une fois je pense que
la démocratie ce n'est pas le rejet des
règles
vous comme moi vous comme moi donc je ne
suis pas dans le rejet des règles je me
fie à ces règles et si les gens
utilisent les règles ils utilisent le
règlement la pétition il y a des règles
jusqu'à un certain taux je n'ai pas
obligé de l'examiner c'était un
rapporteur qui qui fait son travail et
c'est exactement ce pourquoi je suis
devant vous aujourd'hui donc on peut pas
on peut pas refaire les règles en
permanence sous principe que ça vous
gêne ou que les jeunes que les règles
n'ont pas été faites par vous donc vous
êtes je rappelle également aussi que
vous êtes député tout comme moi vous
êtes libre de saisir tous les moyens à
votre disposition s'il y a des sujets
qui vous paraissent importants et je
crois que vous le faites et je crois que
vous le faites donc il est inutile de
dévoyer
inutile de dévoyer le droit à pétition
pour cela vous avez d'autres moyens si
vous voulez mettre des
objets politiques en discussion je note
aussi que la collègue la collègue audiol
d'ailleurs dit que c'est la France
insoumise qui propose cette pétition je
vais passer sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs que monsieur léoman était
souvent cité dans cette pétition donc je
je n'ose penser que ça vient de vous et
je rappelle que l'usage de la force
encore une fois et encadré
et que il n'y a absolument pas de de
remise en cause à aucun moment de cela
et que la pétition
obligatoire n'existait pas et c'est pas
parce que c'est une pétition que c'est
plus apaisé surtout quand on parle dans
cette pétition de massacre et de
policiers meurtriers donc encore une
fois je pense que avoir répondu à peu
près à tout le monde moi il y a des
règles je les respecte le contenu de
cette pétition
UTT différents peut-être que mon
traitement aurait pu aussi évoluer mais
ce n'est pas le cas nous avons
aujourd'hui une pétition qui est une
pétition politique à charge et en plus
qui veut qui utilise voilà des arguments
qui ne sont pas justes je les ai montré
les bravesm font leur travail sont
utiles et les sanctions administratives
et judiciaires s'il y en a contre des
policiers qui auraient mal fait leur
travail seront
un an pas douter mener voilà
bien donc on va passer au vote pour ces
deux pétitions
je me suis Rambo dans ce terminé
d'annoncer le vote
c'est trop tard malheureusement
vous inscrire fallait vous inscrire sur
la première salle alors je rappelle que
c'est la vie du rapporteur que je mets à
au vote et que pour les deux pétitions
successivement le rapporteur avait mis
un avis de classer les pétitions donc
pour le premier avis approuvez-vous la
vie du rapporteur de classer la pétition
pour la dissolution de la braven qui
vote pour
qui va être contre
la pétition est classée approuvez-vous
la vie du rapporteur de classer la
pétition pour le maintien de la braven
qui vote pour
qui votre contre la pétition est
également classée nous passons
maintenant à la troisième pétition qui
s'intitule soutenez vous la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle instaurant le
référendum initiative citoyenne en
matière constitutionnelle monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole pour nous
présenter votre avis merci monsieur le
Président donc là la pétition on s'en F
qui date du 11 novembre dernier et
recueilli près de 16000 signatures
proposent quand elles la création d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne RIC en
matière de révision constitutionnelle
cela conduirait à modifier l'article 89
de la Constitution relatif à la
procédure de révision
la proposition de révision
constitutionnelle d'initiative citoyenne
serait d'abord soumise à un contrôle de
recevabilité assuré par un tribunal
judiciaire si elle était recevable et
soutenue par 700 000 citoyens elle
devrait alors être obligatoirement
soumise à référendum la pétition demande
également la suppression de l'alinéa 3
de l'article 89 de la Constitution afin
que les révisions constitutionnelles
initiées par le Président de la
République ne puisse plus être approuvé
par le Parlement réunit en congrès mais
seulement par voie du référendum
actuellement en application de l'article
89 de la Constitution l'initiative d'une
révision constitutionnelle appartient au
président de la République sur
proposition du Premier ministre et aux
membres du Parlement
après un vote du projet de révision par
les deux Chambres en termes identiques
le président peut décider de le
soumettre soit au référendum soit au
Parlement réuni en Congrès dans ce
dernier cas le projet est approuvé s'il
réunit les trois cinquièmes des
suffrages exprimés
je vous rappelle que la Constitution de
la Cinquième République a été révisée 24
fois
sur ces 24 révisions constitutionnelles
deux ont été approuvés par voie du
référendum
d'abord en 1962 l'élection du Président
de la République au suffrage universel
l'article 11 de la Constitution avait
alors été utilisé pour organiser
directement un référendum sans en saisir
d'abord les assemblées ce qui avait été
contesté notamment par de nombreux
juristes car l'article 11 n'est pas
celui qui concerne la révision
puis en 2000 c'est aussi par référendum
qui a été décidé la réduction de 7 à 5
ans de la durée du mandat présidentiel
mais cette fois selon la procédure qui
est bien celle prévue par l'article 89
c'est à dire pour rappel l'adoption du
texte
c'est à dire après l'adoption du texte
de la révision par les deux assemblées
la révision de l'article 89 proposait
est présentée comme destinée à revigorer
la prise de décision en associant
davantage les citoyens mais elle pose
plusieurs difficultés très sérieuses
tout d'abord le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne est ici conçue comme un outil
de contestation de la représentation
nationale jugée par principe défaillante
pour représenter le peuple alors même
que les membres de l'Assemblée nationale
sont élus au suffrage universel direct
cette approche se situe donc d'emblée
dans une logique qui revient en réalité
à contester le résultat des élections
démocratiques
ainsi le Parlement serait entièrement
exclu du processus puisque la procession
de révision constitutionnelle émanant
des citoyens devraient ensuite être
approuvé directement par e seul
par ailleurs en cas de révision
constitutionnelle d'initiative
présidentielle la révision devrait
obligatoirement être soumise à
référendum alors que la Constitution
actuelle laisse aussi ouverte la voie
d'une adoption par le Congrès et nous
savons bien que cette souplesse peut
être bien utile notamment pour conduire
des révisions très ciblées ou plutôt
techniques
dans les deux cas l'exclusion du
Parlement peut avoir pour effet néfaste
d'affaiblir notre démocratie
représentative et d'alimenter l'anti
parlementarisme
une telle mesure pour illimiter à un
choix binaire des sujets d'une grande
complexité qui nécessite que les débats
soient dépassés
la circulation de fausses informations
peut également avoir une influence sur
le choix du citoyen et constituer ainsi
un véritable danger pour la démocratie
il est donc primordial qu'il y ait des
garde-fous à toute révision de la
Constitution
l'actuel procédure de révision de la
Constitution remplit cette condition
puisqu'elle permet d'éviter une trop
grande instabilité du texte quantique
constitutionnel et comporte des
garanties institutionnelles essentielles
pour notre démocratie mais ce n'est pas
le seul problème que poserait le projet
de réécriture de l'article 89 de la
Constitution tel qu'il est envisagé par
cette pétition et je dirais loin de là
en effet cette pétition sans aucun
argument supprimerait les principes
fondamentaux prévus aux alinés à 4 et 5
de l'article 89 qui prévoit qu'aucune
révision constitutionnelle ne peut être
engagée au poursuivi lorsqu'il est porté
atteinte à l'intégrité du territoire ou
lorsque cela peut obliger de remettre en
cause la forme républicaine du
gouvernement
vous adorez chers collègues que ce n'est
pas un détail
on le voit bien la norme suprême de
notre ordre juridique requier que toute
modification soit mesurée et réfléchie
en outre ce référendum d'initiative
citoyenne ne présenterait pas
suffisamment de garanties procédurale le
contrôle de la recevabilité du projet de
révision serait confié à un tribunal
judiciaire en méconnaissance de la
compétence du Conseil constitutionnel
garant du respect de la Constitution
alors qu'il exerce cette compétence par
exemple à l'occasion des référendums
d'initiatives partagées
enfin nous nous sommes déjà prononcés
récemment à deux reprises sur des
propositions de loi visant à instaurer
la possibilité de référendum initiative
citoyenne notamment pour prévoir la
possibilité de demander par référendum
la convocation d'une Assemblée
constituante or ces deux propositions de
loi ont été rejetées pour toutes ces
raisons je vous propose monsieur le
Président Richard collègues de classer
cette pétition merci monsieur Guillaume
fiévalente pour le groupe Renaissance
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur pour ses propos
éclairants nous voterons notre part le
classement de cette pétition également
merci d'avoir
toutefois soulevé trois points d'abord
et qui se cache derrière
ce RIC à cette proposition de référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et qu'il faut
effectivement décortiquer
et expliquer dans le sens où il
représente un certain nombre d'attaques
envers notre République et nos
institutions d'abord dans le fait que ça
représente une ban
ou une volonté de banaliser le fait de
réviser notre Constitution qui a déjà
été révisé avec 24 prises vous l'avez
rappelé donc c'est bien faisable
aujourd'hui mais à chaque fois la
révision est un moment important et qui
se fait en tremblant d'une certaine
manière et là on le banalise en
expliquant qu'on pourrait le faire d'une
certaine manière de manière assez simple
la deuxième c'est une attaque en fait
directe envers la démocratie
représentative et envers nos
institutions qui se cachent derrière
alors assumer par celles et ceux qui la
défendent puisque c'est le projet
politique qu'il porte c'est voilà et
projet que nous combattants bien entendu
en défendant et nous y croyons la
démocratie représentative ce qui
n'empêche pas de développer qui
n'empêche pas de développer aujourd'hui
la participation citoyenne mais tout en
respectant la démocratie représentative
qui permet effectivement de prendre des
décisions dans un cadre légal bien
établi le dernier point que vous souliez
c'est l'attaque envers un certain nombre
de principes fondamentaux de notre
constitution de notre République que
nous ne pouvons bien entendu en aucun
cas cautionner pour ces raisons nous
voterons le classement de cette pétition
madame Marie-France Loreau regroupe
nationale merci monsieur le Président le
groupe rassemblement national se réjouit
que des citoyens proposent des pétitions
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale que
nous soyons favorable non au sujet
proposés elles ont le mérite de
permettre de créer un débat public la
pétition proposée pour soutenir une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
instaurant le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne en matière constitutionnelle
rique a recueilli 15000 signatures le
but est de rétablir la confiance des
citoyens dans la Constitution comme le
Parlement avec l'instauration d'un
contrôle démocratique direct sur la
politique grâce au recours du référendum
mais la modification de l'article 89 de
la Constitution proposée porte
uniquement sur la matière
constitutionnelle face à la fracture
démocratique résultat du premier
quinquennat Macron la réponse du
rassemblement national est simple Marine
Le Pen porte le projet d'une renaissance
démocratique réalisable grâce à
l'instauration de la proportionnelle et
d'un référendum référendum d'initiative
citoyenne large symbole de la
souveraineté populaire à laquelle nous
sommes plus que jamais attachés l'Union
nationale reviendra lorsque tout le
monde aura l'impression d'être respecté
lorsque chaque voie contrat notre groupe
est favorable au rythique dans sa forme
législative qui consiste à donner la
possibilité au peuple de soumettre un
texte au référendum mais reste ferme sur
la sauvegarde de l'intégrité de notre
Constitution seul le peuple peut la
modifier mais sur l'initiative du
Président de la République ou des
membres du Parlement en revanche cette
pétition autoriserait sans plus aucune
limite la révision de notre Constitution
il suffirait pour cela que la
proposition de révision recueille au
moins 700 000 signatures pour aboutir à
un référendum
en réalité ce référendum d'initiative
citoyenne constituant mais sérieusement
en péril la pérennité de notre
Constitution pourtant garante de la
stabilité de nos institutions il s'agit
là d'un risque énorme pour l'équilibre
notre démocratie en ce que en ce que ce
référendum pourrait ouvrir la porte un
changement de régime ainsi le
rassemblement national votre a contre
l'examen de cette pétition je vous
remercie
monsieur
on assiste à la même manifestation de la
vision autoritaire et antidémocratique
que vous avez infligé à l'instant à la
pétition populaire pour la dissolution
de la bravème qui rappelons-le encore en
était qu'une pétition pour avoir un
examen en Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire un avis
ça n'avait pas vocation à s'imposer
ensuite dans la loi
on entend que finalement une pétition
pour une révision d'un article de la
Constitution qui donne le droit
référendum
d'initiative populaire partagée serait
une atteinte à la démocratie c'est quand
même assez hallucinant ou je ne sais pas
vous êtes pas voisin de la Suisse
peut-être ou on a là un pays qui
lui-même et d'origine parlementaire dont
le fonctionnement politique est
parlementaire et qui soumet
régulièrement à l'initiative des
citoyens des référendums à sa population
je ne vois pas que soit un pays in
libéral sur le plan politique mais bon
je comprends aussi que le référent le
référendum de 2005 qui avait eu qui
avait été largement refusé par le
suffrage populaire a été ensuite dissout
dans la volonté gouvernementale de ne
pas en tenir compte alors il y a
vraiment un problème avec les démocratie
puisque d'un coup d'un côté on a la
tartufferie qui consiste à dire que
celui qui était lui au suffrage
universel a finalement toutes les
légitimités pour appliquer toutes ces
tous ces caprices c'est ce que nous
voyons aujourd'hui avec Macron et puis
que de notre côté quand il s'agit de
s'adresser directement au peuple alors
là il n'a plus de légitimité le peuple
alors vous voyez bien il y a quelque
chose qui est complètement aberrant et
qui est le signe vraiment d'un anti
anti-démocratique dans dans toutes les
expressions de la droite à l'extrême
droite
monsieur avait Solignac pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le Président alors on va
peut-être pas procéder tel que les
pétitionnaires le souhaitent et on
votera le classement de cette pétition
parce que nous sommes attachés à la
démocratie représentative parce que nous
avons eu l'occasion aussi d'examiner
deux propositions de loi qui ont été
rejetées et l'une et l'autre parce que
nous pensons que la démocratie ça n'est
pas seulement modifié l'article 89 une
modification qui part ailleurs pourrait
entraîner des initiatives extrêmement
dangereuses et on pourrait imaginer des
référendums sur tous les sujets y
compris sur la réintégration de la peine
de mort il n'en demeure pas moins que
les Français sont je crois de plus en
plus nombreux à s'interroger sur ce
qu'on pourrait appeler nos règles
suprême sur notre cadre institutionnel
et pour celles et ceux c'est pas le cas
de tout le monde ici mais qui ont
participé à quelques manifestations
beaucoup probablement dû entendre à quel
point cette crise politique était en
train de se transformer en une crise de
régime et que c'est
désormais non plus seulement
contestation d'une réforme adoptée dans
les conditions qu'on connaît qui fait
l'objet des débats dans la rue c'est la
contestation des règles qui régissent
notre démocratie notre vie publique
notre République
et qui
occupe l'essentiel des débats et donc il
va falloir se résoudre un jour à
interroger ces règles-là à imaginer
probablement de meilleures coopérations
du citoyen à la chose publique si on
veut que la défiance qui est en train de
s'installer ne se termine pas mal comme
on pourrait le redouter il y a des
citoyens qui sont nombreux qui se sont
exclus de la vie publique des processus
de décision mais encore une fois la
solution ne réside pas dans une
opposition entre les élus et les
citoyens tels que cette pétition la
porte voilà
merci Monsieur Philippe Pradal
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur cher collègue dans leur
grande sagesse il est constituant en
1958 ont fait le choix d'organiser les
modalités de révision de la Constitution
alors que pendant longtemps le mode
principal de révision était le coup
d'état ou la progression le texte de
l'article 89 notre Constitution est
claire le référendum est prévu pour
approuver une modification de la
Constitution la pétition qui nous est
soumise demande de supprimer la voie
alternative parlementaire ce qui paraît
au groupe horizon et apparenté
inutile et risqué
inutile parce que la voie référendaire
existe déjà dans notre texte fondateur
je le disais même si elle fut peu
utilisée et parfois même contestée cette
modification de la Constitution par
référendum existe et a été appliqué
risqué parce que le mode de révision par
le Congrès peut permettre une souplesse
et une efficacité largement utilisée
risquez également parce que la rédaction
retenue peut alimenter une forme de
contestation de la démocratie
représentative qui demeure un des
piliers du fonctionnement de notre
système démocratique risquez enfin parce
que des principes essentiels pourraient
être effacés par cette pétition et
notamment l'impossibilité de réviser la
Constitution lorsqu'il est porté
atteinte à l'intégrité du territoire
ainsi que l'impossibilité de remettre en
cause la forme républicaine du
gouvernement le groupe horizon et
apparenté convaincu qu'on ne saurait
opposé les souverainetés et c'est ce que
suggère finalement cette pétition par la
suppression pure et simple de
l'approbation par le Congrès elle
soustant un manque de légitimité de ce
dernier ou en tout état de cause une
moindre légitimité à se prononcer sur
une révision constitutionnelle que celle
du peuple directement si notre
démocratie donc notre République ont
toujours besoin de s'interroger et
d'évoluer il importe de le faire avec
prudence et dans le souhait de maintenir
des équilibres il faut se garder du
mirage qui consisterait à croire que
seule une révision formelle visant à
réduire le rôle du Parlement permettrait
d'accroître la participation des
citoyens aux élections le groupe horizon
et apparenté souhaite donc que cette
pétition soit classée et puisque chacun
contribue à l'historiographie
Robespierre je citerai Olympe de Gouges
enfants de la Patrie vous vengerez ma
mort alors que Robespierre venait de
l'envoyer sur les chapeaux
merci monsieur jérémyordanov
merci monsieur le Président alors je je
sur le débat je reviendrai sur le fond
tout à l'heure mais je veux dire que la
question qui nous est posée aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si on classe cette
pétition ou si on l'examine c'est pas de
savoir si sur le fond on est d'accord ou
si on n'est pas d'accord donc moi je
veux alerter ici tout un chacun sur la
situation politique traverse notre pays
aujourd'hui je rejoins les mots qui ont
été prononcés tout à l'heure moi je
pense qu'on est dans une crise de régime
dans le sens où c'est plus le fond de la
réforme des retraites qui est attaquée
maintenant c'est l'âge du 49-3 et c'est
l'ensemble des institutions et je crois
que la manière on n'a pas le temps de
développer ici mais dans la cinquième
république aujourd'hui est pratiquée ne
correspond même plus à l'esprit de la
Constitution
rédigée donc je crois qu'il faut prendre
ce sujet au sérieux et il faut que
l'Assemblée nationale se saisisse de
sujet donc moi je souhaiterais qu'on
étudie ces questions là même si on peut
ne pas être d'accord sur certaines
modalités qui sont proposées là je pense
qu'on a intérêt plutôt à aller vers
l'étude de ces objets là
sur le moi notamment sur le texte qui
nous est proposé je pense que c'est ça
pourrait être intéressant d'harmoniser
les procédures qui sont proposées que
l'initiative vienne du président de la
République ou du Parlement pourquoi
est-ce que quand c'est le président de
la République on peut passer en congrès
ou en référendum et quand c'est le
Parlement c'est uniquement référendum je
pense qu'il y a cette question là qu'on
peut soulever la deuxième question c'est
quelle est la place des citoyens dans ce
processus là moi je comprends qu'il faut
et je suis pas anti parlementariste je
pense qu'il faut un espace de
délibération avant que le texte puisse
être soumis à référendum donc moi je
pense qu'il ne faut pas contourner le
Parlement mais on pourrait imaginer une
procédure d'initiative partagée comme ça
existe pour des ex législatifs qui ne
sont pas constitutionnelles donc voilà
je pense que ces questions là il faut
les avoir dans le débat donc moi nous on
les écoles pour le pour le rapport et
pour avancer sur ces questions là je
vous remercie madame Elisa Martin
merci
nous simplement à ce que l'on ce que
l'on veut dire c'est que tout ce qui
permet l'éruption citoyenne tout ce qui
permet une forme de de de frottement
dialectique entre les citoyens et la
démocratie dite représentative organisée
telle qu'elle est et quelque chose de
positif que tout ce qui va disputer la
place de la Cinquième République la
logique de monarchie présidentielle est
quelque chose qui me qui nous paraît
positif c'est ce que vient de dire
Jérémy Jordan afin il s'agit pas
forcément de se prononcer au fond en
tant que tel sur la nature même de la
proposition mais de saisir à quel élan
ça correspond et puis après moi j'ai
envie de dire faut pas se plaindre
si il n'est jamais donné aucun espace
aux citoyen de quelques natures que ce
soit bah il va rester la rue dans les
meilleures conditions celle qu'on
souhaite et puis dans les pires celle
que vous organisez puisque c'est
l'après-midi c'est l'après-midi des
provocations et des choses et des choses
correctes à s'échanger bon voilà nous
quel est notre position en un mot tout
ce qui permet l'éruption citoyenne tout
ce qui permet aux citoyens de trouver
des voies et des moyens pour se
prononcer sur un certain nombre de
sujets doit être regardé avec attention
monsieur le rapporteur pour vos réponses
merci monsieur le Président bon la
première éruption citoyenne moi que je
vois c'est le vote donc d'ailleurs ça
marche puisque vous êtes là donc voilà
donc c'est je pense que la démocratie
représentative et ça a été soulignée par
beaucoup de collègues ici c'est que la
démocratie représentative nous est tous
enfin nous est très majoritairement
précieux et en cela cette pétition vient
la RT et donc c'est je rejoins je
remercie tous ceux qui ont qui l'ont
rappelé notamment
que ce soit nos collègues de la majorité
ou nos collègues socialistes qui ça veut
pas dire que effectivement il n'y a pas
de question à se poser ou
d'interrogations à se poser sur le
fonctionnement nos institutions mais on
se doit avant tout de les respecter et
de pas trouver de solutions et j'ai
apprécié la formule qui vise à opposer
les élus aux citoyens mais bien ce qui
ne réglera rien la restauration de la
confiance mais bien justement de trouver
des moyens de dialogue et d'apaisement
plutôt que de la tentation de de la rue
permanente donc je ne doute pas que au
travers de différents travaux je le sais
nous emmenons avec notamment notre
collègue gordanov pour voir comment
justement on peut faire évoluer ces
choses là mais encore une fois nous
sommes là pour voir s'il faut faire
avancer cette pétition qui clairement
va dans une logique anti-parlementariste
d'affaiblissement la démocratie
représentative et de respect de principe
républicains qui sont neutres qui sont
majeurs comme l'intégrité du territoire
et donc je pense que
là dessus heureusement nous avons trouvé
un large consensus pour la classer merci
si monsieur le rapporteur je vais donc
mettre au voile la vie du rapporteur
approuvez-vous la vie du rapporteur de
classer cette pétition qui va être pour
qui votre contre cette position est
classée je vous remercie